ahora trabajaremos el inciso c del
problema de la papa que dice un modelo
alternativo cuando te es menor que 10
para la temperatura interna de la papa
en el tiempo t
en minutos es la función g que satisface
la ecuación diferencial y aquí tengo
esta ecuación diferencial donde je
t'aime está dado en grados celsius y g
de 0 es igual a 91 encuentran la
expresión paraje de t con base en este
modelo cuál es la temperatura interna de
la papa en el tiempo de igual a 3 bueno
nos dan una ecuación diferencial y nos
piden que encontremos una expresión
paraje de t esto es lo que nos están
pidiendo es decir esencialmente nos
piden la solución de esta ecuación
diferencial y después nos piden que
usemos esa solución para encontrar la
temperatura ente igual a 3 ahora lo
primero que quiero que apreciemos es que
esto entra en una clase de cálculo
por lo tanto si te piden que resuelvas
una ecuación diferencial o que des la
solución a una ecuación diferencial
entonces debe de ser una ecuación
diferencial muy fácil de resolver no
debe de ser tan complicada lo más lógico
es que sea una ecuación diferencial
separable y ya que encontremos la
solución entonces podemos evaluar la
gente igual a 3 así que qué te parece si
reescribimos esta ecuación diferencial y
vamos a resolverla y después a evaluarla
ok tengo que la derivada de g con
respecto a t
esto es igual a menos que menos 27 esto
elevado a las dos tercios
entonces si ésta es una ecuación
diferencial separable lo que quiero es
separar a deje ya de t entonces voy a
multiplicar de ambos lados por de t
ok también de este lado por de t ok y
entonces me va a quedar que estos dos se
van
tengo dejé ok
igual a menos que menos 27 a la dos
tercios esto que multiplica a dt lo que
estoy intentando es llevar todas las que
es del lado donde está dejé y todas las
tres del lado donde están
dt así que qué te parece si divido a
ambos lados entre g
- 27 elevado a las dos tercios entonces
voy a dividir de este lado entre g - 27
elevado a las dos tercios
y voy a hacer lo mismo de este lado voy
a dividir esto entre g
-27 ok esto elevado a la dos tercios y
entonces me va a quedar bueno del lado
izquierdo me va a quedar g
-27 elevado a la menos dos tercios ok a
la menos dos tercios que multiplican
adeje va a ser igual y observa estos dos
se van y me va a quedar simplemente
menos
dt no olvides este signo menos me va a
quedar menos
dt
ok y ahora podemos integrar de ambos
lados así que déjame ponerlo voy a
integrar de ambos lados tanto de este
lado como de este lado y que obtengo
bueno observan tengo la integral de esta
expresión que tengo aquí entonces puedes
intentar hacer un cambio de variable y
decir que uno es igual a menos 27 y por
lo tanto de un es igual a deje o
simplemente reconocer que la derivada de
g menos 27 con respecto a g es
simplemente 1 por lo tanto puedo ponerlo
aquí es 1 ok 1 que multiplicaría a todo
esto y por lo tanto puedo integrar con
respecto a g menos 27 y usar simplemente
la inversa de la regla de la potencia es
decir esto me quedaría en menos 27
- 27 elevado a la potencia menos dos
tercios más uno bueno menos dos tercios
más uno es lo mismo que un tercio ok
elevado a la potencia un tercio ya esto
hay que dividirlo entre un tercio pero
ojo dividir entre un tercio es lo mismo
que multiplicar por tres entonces voy a
multiplicar por tres y esto va a ser
igual ok a la integral de menos de temp
es como si tuviéramos un 1 aquí menos
uno de t lo cual es simplemente menos t
y para terminar bien vamos a sumarle una
constante de integración ok ahora cómo
resolvemos para hacer bueno usando la
información que nos dan porque nos dicen
que g de 0 es igual a 91 es decir que
cuando te es igual a 0 que es igual a 91
y podemos así obtener el valor de s es
decir esto me va a quedar como 3
que multiplica a gm pero cuando te es
igual a cero es igual a 91 entonces 91
menos 27
ok esto elevado a la un tercio y esto va
a ser igual a ten pero te vale 0
entonces podremos poner aquí cero o
simplemente no ponerlo y va a ser igual
a ser que es lo que buscamos el valor de
esta c y bueno cuantos esto tengo 91 27
eso es 64 entonces estos 64 elevado a la
un tercio bueno eso es simplemente 4
entonces esto elevado de un tercio es 4
y 4 por 3 es 12 entonces puedo decir que
es igual a 12 y aquí en lugar de estas
en poner el valor de 2 muy bien ahora
vamos a buscar la expresión para que dt
que esencialmente es despejar de aquí ag
déjame decir que voy a continuar por acá
ok y ahora qué te parece si te pido de
ambos lados entre 3 si / de ambos lados
entre 3 de este lado me va a quedar
simplemente que menos 27 ok
-27 esto elevado a un tercio
y esto va a ser igual a bueno menos de
entre 3 déjame ponerlo menos tema entre
3 y después tengo 12 entre 3 lo cual es
simplemente 4 + 4 ok y ahora se me
ocurre que puedo elevar de ambos lados
al cubo si el nuevo de este lado al cubo
me va a quedar simplemente en que menos
y del lado derecho me queda esto elevado
al cubo así que déjame ponerlo me queda
menos de entre 3 menos de entre 34 ok
esto elevado al cubo
ok ahora puedo sumar 27 de ambos lados y
ahora si voy a obtener kg
o dicho de otra manera je t'aime porque
es una función del tiempo es igual y
ahora si un redoble de tambor porque ya
puedo decir que es lo mismo que menos te
entre 3 a esto sumarle 4 ok
elevado al cubo y sumarle 27
y ahora si puedo decir que he encontrado
la primera parte de este problema que me
decía encuentran una expresión para tdt
es decir acabamos de encontrar esta
parte de aquí en efecto fue una ecuación
diferencial separable en la que con un
poco de álgebra llegamos al resultado
integramos y encontramos la solución
general y con la condición inicial de
que gt 0 es igual a 91 encontramos la
solución particular que nosotros
buscábamos ahora hagamos la otra parte
que es la parte más fácil dicen con base
en este modelo cuál es la temperatura
interna de la papa en el tiempo pero
igual a 3
bueno pues vamos a hacerlo queremos
saber cuánto es que de 3 bueno es
simplemente sustituir a t por 3 me va a
quedar menos 3 entre 3
+ 4 esto elevado al cubo y después le
sumamos 27 bueno menos 3 entre 3
es simplemente menos 1 ok menos 14
todo esto es simplemente 33 elevado al
cubo es 27 más 27 es 54 54 grados
celsius y hemos acabado todo el problema
de la papa